we are here with bournatural who is the
one of the top players tennis players in
the world and also the best player of
Croatia so today you you had this very
interesting experience to make the first
symbolic movement the game and the chess
on the chessboard and also had
experience to watch the games that
they're playing oh how did you like it
yeah yeah absolutely it was it was a
very very cool experience for me I've
never been on the on the on the chess
tournament and I was I was really
looking forward to this and obviously I
I I also saw the players and I and I met
the players I'm just very very happy to
be here yeah so on which board did you
make the first move and who is who are
you rooting for in this tournament uh I
need to root obviously obviously for the
charge uh also he's my favorite player
and I've been I've been following him a
little bit in the in the last few months
so yeah hopefully he came in the
tournament yeah the
I'm actually very very bad in the chest
to be honest so I just played you know
for fun and and to relax a little bit
after after all the matches but uh again
uh unfortunately I'm um I'm just not
very good do you play online or you play
with your friends and who taught you to
play actually
um
actually my friends and I uh I would say
I I explain mostly online online is
mostly and also Summers with the friends
like this but uh but mostly
Enlightenment when I have free time on
the tournaments yeah for sure and what
are your plans for the future where do
you go next uh plans for the future I'm
actually going for location for the
couple of days it's been it's been a
very very tough season uh and at this
time in tennis we actually have
um I would send you a couple of days
where where we can take a break so I'm
gonna go home and I'm I'm gonna just
relax for a couple of days yeah so have
a great vacations and enjoy the
tournament thank you very much thank you